today is election day in Alabama we have
accused Republican serial child sex
abuse or Roy Moore versus Democrat Doug
Jones the last 24 hours of the race have
been weird Roy Moore was interviewed by
a twelve-year-old girl which just looks
odd when he's accused of sexually
assaulting multiple girls but the real
sort of cherry on top the real bizarre
and disturbing element is that one of
Roy mores friends a guy that he served
with in Vietnam has admitted that he
went to a Vietnamese brothel with child
prostitutes with Roy Moore but the
totally bonkers element of it is that
this wasn't someone who was out there
criticizing Roy Moore one of Roy Moore's
friends who introduced him at a campaign
rally yesterday and I guess was trying
to talk about how great Roy Moore is
admitted that he went to a child brothel
in Vietnam with Roy Moore how is this
even possible well bills stale or Staley
says that he served with Roy Moore in
Vietnam and that one night the two of
them plus another guy went to a
so-called private club which actually
turned out to be a brothel with little
girls as prostitutes and Staley told his
story apparently to defend Roy Moore by
saying we did go and there were little
girl prostitutes but Roy Moore did the
right thing he refused to have sex with
the little girls only our third buddy
did the defense of Roy Moore is that he
went to the brothel but he didn't have
sex with the little girls here is the
delusional and unbelievable video from
this rally last night where bill Staley
told the story
[Music]
we walked inside I can tell you the less
time it took for some of the populace
and there were certainly three girls and
they were
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
why is the crowd laughing there's
nothing funny about this story I guess
it's supposed to be a story showing how
great Roy Moore is because he had the
opportunity to have sex with little
girls in Vietnam but he chose not to so
you should vote for him today
apparently I mean who hasn't
accidentally stumbled into a child
brothel happens to most men I know
anytime they travel outside the United
States
I actually don't believe the guy I had
no idea about the story but the one
thing that doesn't fit in the story is
that Roy Moore showed up and immediately
said this just isn't right let's leave
now I don't that's the one part of the
story I call into question I think I
believe the story though I think because
if he was trying to manufacture
something Roy Moore would have been the
hero and told the third guy to come
along with them or ratted him out or
something like but that's why I think
that this is a terrible story because
they're basically saying we just allowed
guy number three to stay and and have
sex with little girls like if you really
want to show that you did the right
thing and that you have morals you
should have told the guy number three
listen these are children don't have sex
with them let's go somewhere else
but they didn't do that they're not even
lying that they did that they just did
even if this story is true it doesn't
undermine the accounts of multiple women
who have accused Roy Moore of sexual
misconduct course and the bar is so low
for Roy Moore that I guess bill Staley
thought a good way to defend him is to
cite a time when he could have molested
little girls but didn't right I wonder
whether this was planned as a story to
help Roy Moore or whether this guy went
off script with the story like imagine
the conversation just offstage before
someone hands bill Staley the microphone
and says okay bill you're on next now
remember no stories about sex with kids
do not mention sex with children got it
yes I got it
oops I forgot and I'm not even going to
mention the polling in this
race okay all I'm going to say is the
election is today vote today if you need
a ride to the polls you can call 804 8
402 17 if you have a problem voting
call